Hello, this is
Ken and I'm going over my
Discord clone slash Discordant
AI robot everything tool.
And what we're looking at right now is a
sign in and we have two separate pages
that are signing in here. And
so we're going to go ahead and sign in as
me
and then once as.
My partner.
I go to my homepage, which is my home
server is called kendev and you can see
that I have all these people who are
members of my server here.
And you can see that I've been busy
on this today.
Uh I've been running tests and stuff for
quite a while. Is what this is,
is whenever I post a message or you post
a message or
anybody posts a message to this, it goes
through the
nation back end. And
So what that nation is,
is N aid in. I call it nation. They don't
even call it nation. I don't know why I
do, but I do. I just think it sounds like
it and we can see right here.
anytime I send a message
into the server
like the one I just sent to
add Max's appointment next week
a party at sunset point after dog park
after 6 p.m. so it added
it in here and then it
created the event right here and I'm
still working on formatting that but
We go right here. Let's see if we get
that event.
Yep, party at sunset point
at 6:00 PM after Max's appointment.
So what we've got here right now
is a working
system where
I have every message that comes
into this server, which also
coincidentally is a.
Uh, multi-user.
I have an issue with running multiple
cameras right now. I don't know why. Um,
uh, let me deactivate.
There it goes. OK, so now
we have this and I can also get in here
and. Share my screen
or whatever. And then so
right now I'm in the video channel here.
I won't be able to do that,
but I can go to the video channel here
and I'm in my Code with Kenda
video channel and you can
see me
right there and this will work.
And number of users. So anybody who's
into this channel and this little
conference like Teams,
when you enter a channel, it should be
talking about a message in here that was
searchable.
And as you can see, so I was at the
Enterprise dog park and I just uploaded
this and I was there.
This could create an ongoing journal or
whatever into that workflow.
And again, that workflow can recurse back
into this. So when we look at theworkflow,
my workflow actually has a tool
to get the messages from the database. So
this is actually loading uh
the last 20 messages from the channel
whenever a request comes in. So this is
very performant. So and then the other
thing is, is that we're going to be
building this into a custom query tool.
So what'll happen is, is when you when
you perform any search in here,
like for example.
Right here, we just asked for a GSA
analysis and now we're looking at our our
workflow coming in here,
right?And we can see
that it's hit our workflow. We don't see
any of the animations that are happening.
If this was running in test mode, you
could actually see these nodes animating
as they execute. It's really fun to
watch.
Yeah.
So this is a report and this
this is so if you're like working on a
prospect and I want to know
about Gulf Coast aluminum products, this
will actually go out and do
a pretty cool report
giving you all of the various GSA
schedules and value
propositions and things like that for the
customer. Can go out and
actually research the CEO of the company
or who the best contact is,
if they have any contracts or already
pretty much anything. And right now
what we're looking at is the actual flow
that is implemented right now.
So I get the latest messages here.
I have a few calendar events. I can
connect this to any Google Calendar or
also up to Sugar CRM, for example.
Um And then this is my calendar with all
of these different events that I've been
managing with my
site AI. So really there
isn't anything that can't be done with
this. When you submit a uh
A picture into
it, you know
OK, so that still pops in. That's a
little is minor,
but you get the picture,
sort of.
But what we can do is use this as the
foundation for a complete business
intelligence system, because every
message becomes part of the retrieval
augmented storage system, otherwise known
as retrieval augmented,
right?So anyway, each of
these messages have an internal Jason
structure that enables them to store
anything and then be queried
on that intelligently with Jason.
Syntax, if you will. But this
is very handy already. And also note
things like a report comes
back. It's long. It just shows you enough
to wet your whistle so you know what it
is. And then you can expand it out. Show
more 32 lines here
and we can. OK, that's good. And
now we'll be able to search and maybe
we'll have a separate search up here that
you could filter messages by whatever. I
think you need to have that. But with the
intelligent search, what this does is
this actually has access to all the
messages that you have permission on.
So all the messages in all the different
servers you have permissions on
this does. So this is
very powerful and
and again we go into our
workflow editor here. I can add an
e-mail. I want to add
a e-mail, send
mail. I can add a Gmail though. Boom
uh get many messages so I can I can
create a whole e-mail agent that
all it does is I could be in there and
say send a e-mail to him and then have an
e-mail agent on here that drafts a really
nice e-mail showing exactly how.
This can benefit that particular client
and then it can record it in the CRM
and because I can link in to Sugar.
So if I add Sugar,
so we have Zoho Agile CRM
and if we don't have a CRM it doesn't
matter because these code nodes are
incredibly sophisticated. Just so you
know, these things are like.
Crazy sophisticated and
the model just whips him out in a
heartbeat. And that's the part I'm not
the secret sauce. I'm not showing how I
built it. You don't need to know that
anyhow, but I do have a very
rapid and effective workflow. So anytime
you want to change your business logic or
add something new, I want to. Now
I want to be able to update contact
records. I just go ahead and plop that
tool right on to the agent right here
and we can get more sophisticated. This
this is just from a day's well two days
worth of tinkering that I have a general
services AI which can schedule
events, any kind of
event and it can also.
In addition, it can also do the research,
which I'm still working on this tool, but
this tool right here, just to give a
little perspective,
is also
183 lines of code.
So and what this tool is doing is
actually going out to or will be
going out to Google using a
custom search API to go
get. Information about that company,
return that, take all of that and put
that into that nice pretty report about
the company and then that becomes
searchable by anybody and it's
instantaneously. So now you have all of
that information and we can go way deeper
than that surface. I have
looked at other workflows which are
that just make this look like child's
play, but the great thing is, is that.
This system supports that right
out-of-the-box, so I can increase these
workflows. These nation open source
free to run workflows are very
inexpensive. I mean, you can self host or
I can host it for you, or I can set up an
identical copy of my hosting environment,
which while we're at it is a
Windows Server. And
I also host things like Uptime Kuma,
which is an uptime monitoring tool. to
ensure that all the services are running
properly. And I also
have...
Gotta run it slow here.
Alright, slower molasses going uphill on
a cold day in January in
Alaska.
Oh, here's Uptime Kuma.
OK, my memory resources are dragging on
the server. It's must be,
but you get the picture. So what we have
here is a system which say for
example, like I said, I come in here and
I put in my mileage. Now it's a mileage
log or if I put in this
this customer and I want to look it up,
it will record that customer into the
CRM. And update it saying that we
researched it. So now we'll put a CRM
record in for this and maybe attach this
whole report into that CRM record.
And then you would also be able to click
on the link in this to get to that CRM
record that it just created, for example.
So really actually there's nothing that
cannot be rapidly
implemented into this tool, so we
can. Whether it's scheduling events
where you